say I have a lot of mental anguish
myself oh you do yes sir
what do you think caused that family
mainly like I said mother heroin addict
prostitute father Hells Angels biker
heroin addict just all kinds of crazy
stuff like they told me I was born dead
I guess with the umbilical cord wrapped
around my neck from the accident of my
mother got into she didn't have me in
Oklahoma where they were supposed to
where she got an axe in the net she flew
back to California to have me and that's
why I was born dead and then so they did
an emergency c-section whatever saved my
life
but then it's six months old I guess
they told me that I had colic and then I
was ruining their high so they drove
down the road we lived right on Lake
Elsinore they drove down the road threw
me in the lake at six months old
and my father and mother were telling me
this story like they were talking about
the weather you know like no big thing
and they're like yeah you were ruining
our high so we threw you in the lake you
know and went back home fixed you know
got high we were kicking it about ready
to fix it again like four hours later
when we hear this knocking scratching on
the door
dad kept opening the door didn't see
anybody so he's getting pissed you know
like the fifth sixth time he said I was
gonna just murder somebody I thought
someone was dingdong ditching you know
and coming to find out the sixth time he
opens in right before he closes he looks
down and he sees me soaking wet smiling
that I'm not coughing so they let me in
and that's that's how they finished the
story they're like you basically weren't
a buzzkill anymore so we let you in I
was like all right thank you
I was horrible grew up watching mother
sucking [ __ ] for money you know for dope
like be in the same bed and everything
you know yes I was pretty horrible and
then watching her just do all kind a guy
actually watched her five to six years
old beat some man to death in a hardware
store out in Riverside the dude cut us
off and we were in a pickup truck with
no lap belts because there's an older
truck and she slammed on her brakes I
flew into the - busted my nose that
pissed her off so she ran a couple red
lights chasing the dude down chased him
he pulled into a hardware store she
jumps out after him she's like wait here
in the truck I'm like oh hell no you
know I was a little kid I wanted to see
what was going on and followed her in
and just watched her beat this man to
death with tools off of the shelves
yeah like giant wrenches you know a
hammer I think was the hammer or
something big like a pickaxe or
something was the final tool that she
used to kill the guy he stopped moving
stop crying
so she gets up off of him spits on him
and she sees me and she just grabs me
she's like I'd told you to wait in the
[ __ ] truck come on let's go
I mean like five or six and then she did
get caught though trying to break my
stepdad out of out of jail like he was
in Riverside County and they planned on
an escape whatever but he blabbermouth
to his cellie and celery ratted him off
so me mom and sister and little brother
brother was a baby at the time we go
walking in the Riverside County
Courthouse and just get bum-rushed by
like 20 million
sheriff's or whatever you know the DEA's
that protect the place of bailiffs I
guess and they tackled her she had two
45s on her and she's like in thoroughly
like escaping from jail you know and
then that's when we got sent to foster
homes and foster home thing was like a
real hectic ordeal because they were
always like splitting us apart you know
and then finally I got placed new a
foster home Thomas Lee West jr. his
uncle is Jerry West the owner of the
Lakers he molested me for five to six
years of my life
beat me thoroughly to like one time I
caught the house a little bit on fire
cuz he told me to start the barbecue I
was like ten years old you know I didn't
know how to start no barbecue I got
gasoline you know that's what I thought
and the charcoals you know poured gas on
the charcoals laid it up and the flames
started dripping out of the the bottom
you know cuz I poured too much gas on
and it caught the hose on fire which put
a black mark on the side of the house
you know cuz it burnt the house a little
bit and so he beat me with the barbecue
like beat me with it you know I was like
he was something he was my teacher to
teacher slash foster parent and so after
going through that for like five to six
years of my life I finally ran away
because he said he was gonna do the same
thing to my little brother that he was
doing to me because I was telling you
know I didn't want to do it anymore I'd
you know I was finally like getting old
enough to stand up for myself and you
know not be so scared and everything he
was 64 you know 207 pounds and I was
like tiny little nothing you know suck
his dick basically I mean and then like
I don't know how sex like that guy he
was like imitates X but like shave his
uh his uh his legs or whatever you know
and tell me to you know basically have
intercourse with his legs you know I'm
saying and and then he would suck my my
dick to you know ten to fifteen and then
so after I ran away and told the cops
you know they still didn't take away his
teachers license or his foster parent
license because he still unfortunately
ruined six other children's lives after
mine and so when I was like 23 or 24 or
something like that
Riverside finally called me and said
asked me to testify you know I came out
and you know I was I was pumped you know
like oh right you know I'm not this
little kid no more you know um you know
feeling uh you know antsy you know like
I wanted to I wanted to hurt him
basically do what he did to me you know
but then when they got down to it I was
there and I was just going off on him
just yelling at him calling him all
kinds of names and I even spit in his
face you know right there in the court
and the bailiffs didn't do nothing they
were like we were hoping that he were
gonna beat his ass we weren't gonna
touch you we were just gonna let you do
it you know and I didn't because I was
afraid that I go to jail
for it you know and I mean a part of me
said I didn't I don't care but then the
part of me that's like the good part I
consider said you're just gonna be like
him you know like what good is it gonna
really do you to assault this man he's
sitting here and he was crying too you
know as I was going off on him you know
so I mean that like I guess it made me
feel empowered in a way you know that I
wasn't a weak little kid and that I got
this big man crying you know and like
scared basically you know yeah I think
it was like 42 years or something to
life and I don't know if he's still
alive or not my stepfather and family
and stuff said that they're gonna put
word in to have him taken care of you
know so I don't know if he's still alive
or not
went to grandmother's sister was there
for like a year or two before me and my
little brother and straight-a student I
was actually nation's top five percent
of high school students yeah I had a
scholarship to to anywhere Harvard Yale
anywhere but I didn't find that
information out until I was 26 because
my mother she kept all the letters from
me and that like she set it up one day
she's like yeah gave me some cigarettes
from my bed table because I was letting
her live with me I had a house and
everything was taking care of her
because she had lung cancer COPD
basically the life of a drug addict you
know was really hard on her so she
needed taken care of you know so I was
taking care of her and stuff you know
paying the bills everything doing
everything right and she's like yeah
give me some cigarettes and I went
grabbed her cigarettes and then I see
this letter sitting right on top of her
pack of cigarettes with my name on it
and another letter underneath it one was
open and the other one was still closed
I look at it and I read it like what the
[ __ ] you know how come you didn't tell
me I had a scholarship she goes I didn't
want you to shine brighter than me I'm
like me shine brighter than you I'm like
mom you're a black hole you know there's
no shining coming from you whatsoever so
I mean for me to shine brighter than you
I don't really have to do all too much
you know but basically I was 17 just to
have this prosthetic knee put in for a
motorcycle accident still had the
stitches and everything and my family
left me homeless while I was still in
high school because mother put all the
blame for all this stuff she stole all
on me and grandmother like we would show
me and my sister and brother we would
show grandmother
doh and everything that mom had you know
trying to get mom some help you know but
grandma wouldn't have it you know your
mother's no drug addict blah blah blah
we take her into the bathroom a needle
sitting in my mom's arm you know blood
everywhere
dope everywhere and our grandma would
say why are you guys trying to set up
your mother for me to get mad at her
we're like we don't want you mad at her
we want you to put her into rehab so she
can get better you know that's all we
wanted but she just couldn't have it
because I mean for her I guess to admit
that her daughter was junkie would I
guess
reflect on her you know so she she
wasn't having none of that so they left
me homeless still crutches holding boxes
of my stuff still in high school and I
basically had to drop out and start
selling drugs so I could survive
for years heroin now it's a fan no
haven't touched heroin since October
14th I got when I went into rehab and
everything detoxed and everything you
know and got out and I was like doing
good but then like stress stressors come
at me and that pretty much brings me
back into the game you know mother
passed away father passed away
grandmother's still around brother and
sister and grandmother in Arizona right
now but that's where I left though to
come out here because I had to get away
from my ex out there cuz she's a total
psychopath she slept with a cop that she
had arrest me for criminal damage and
the criminal damage was her breaking my
dishes over my head you know but because
she was sleeping with him hence the
criminal damage you know and then they
they said it was a domestic dispute - so
they made me go to anger management
domestic classes you know domestic
violence classes whatever and stuff like
that you know and I did all that I mean
past all that with flying colors you
know did the probation thing for three
years past that - and then found out
though that she was cheating on me was a
bunch of people you know - but I'm not
sure if there
I got raised them for the first 10 years
of their life you know but finding out
that she's sleeping with all of her
ex-boyfriends
you know people she went to school with
people she works with you know all kinds
of people because they were sending her
she even had a secret phone that I
didn't know about they were sending her
text messages on stuff I go so when's
that piece of [ __ ] gonna go to work so I
can come by and see you and the kids
this is on my birthday and then another
text was show me your boobs I'm like
like what kind of an immature childish
[ __ ] as is I showed it to her she didn't
want to even look at it though you know
she's like leave me alone I'm busy
because she was on Facebook so inside I
called Facebook [ __ ] I pan handle or
recycle trying to keep it as legitimate
as possible I mean I would love to get a
job but you can't really acquire a job
without an address I mean they tell you
you can if you lie and put down somebody
else's address but for me like that's
just appalling you know how are you
gonna hire somebody and tell them
initially before they even start working
to lie you know that doesn't seem like
the kind of relationship that you would
want to have transpire for somebody
that's gonna be working with you you
know their initial appearance starts off
with a lie about where they live and so
I just told him like I just told him
honest I was like I don't know anybody
out here I don't know any addresses that
I could use you know
so it got hired and fired like right
things in there yeah get back in the
school definitely get off of drugs and
[Music]
hopefully do something to better society
you know like I have all the kinds of
ideas you know like when I was in
seventh grade I came up with a science
fair project how to clean pools
chemical-free
with UV lights you pass water underneath
it and it destabilizes the molecules
original make up of h2o and reforms it
in h2o to hydrogen peroxide as long as
it's in a enclosed containment system
with no outer light you know available
and then when you put it back into the
pool after cycling the peroxide in with
regular water it kills 99.9% of germs
and bacteria and stuff but you put it
back into the pool during the day in the
Sun having all the UV rays transforms
the molecules back to their original
state of h2o so it's water cleaning
water very much
yeah one of the science fair with it
figured I'd get probably millions just
you know not putting it out there but
I'm sure that finding out cuz its
seventh grade a long time ago somebody's
already thought of the idea or utilized
my idea to do something I think you know
yeah I appreciate you very much and what
you're doing thank you very much God
glad you came
you